joining us now labor market analyst
jihad Bosh from the University of
duisburg-essen a German companies
changing their minds when it comes to
all the workers do you think or are they
acting out of necessity they are acting
out of necessity is he got used to early
retirement which was subsidized
subsidized by the state but now
retirement age is increased and early
retirement is abolished and companies
have to face this situation and suddenly
their workforce is getting older and
they have to retrain them they have to
improve the working conditions to cube
to keep them productive in the company
so obviously fitness classes aren't just
enough know what companies need to do is
a couple of things first they have to
improve working conditions elderly
people cannot lift the same weight as
younger people they have to retrain them
continuously and then they have to
create mixed teams with all the workers
and younger workers co the younger
workers can learn from the orders and
the younger can help see orders what
about the consequences of our higher
retirement age what are they the
consequences is that companies will need
to continue with this learning process
as they have to end the discrimination
of all the workers is a substantial
cultural change in German companies
which are very use orientated and
another consequences is we have some
people who can who cannot work until 67
and we have to find solutions for them
does the labor market therefore have to
become more flexible as well as
companies of course the question is what
it means more flexibility of the labor
market and one is a cultural change on
the labor market as well this means
companies have to be ready to recruit
older workers otherwise they will remain
unemployed so there is a cultural change
also in recruiting required but things
are good right now what about the
economy if it slows down at these older
workers going to be the first ones to
lose their jobs definitely not because
we have a strong employment legislation
in Germany which protects
older workers more than the younger
workers which might also cause a problem
for companies because suddenly they
cannot recruit younger people mr. bosch
will return to you in a moment